TWENTY TWO THE SENATE SESSION
SHALL BEGIN THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA.
ATKINS BAIT. BACKER FOR JESS
BRADFORD BY ADAM CORTEZ THREE
DALLY DODD TORONTO EDMUND GLAZER
GONZALES GROVE. HERZBERG WESTERN
HER TADO JONES CAN LONGER
LAYERED LABOR THE MON BUT WIRE
MELINDA'S MAN. NEWMAN NIELSEN
CONTROL OF BOTH PAM PORTS IN
CHINO. RALPH RUBIO SKINNER STERN
AMBERG BY CAL SKI. WINNER WELL.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING A QUORUM
IS PRESENT FOR THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR HERZBERG. AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY SENATOR MITCH. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR PRESIDENT. GOD OF INFINITE
MERCY AND GOODNESS WE PRAY FOR
THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE. CLEAN MY
MANY RELATIVES DURING THESE DAYS
OF CONFLICT. PLUS THE LEADERS
WITH THE WISDOM VISION
PERSEVERANCE TO BUILD THE WORLD
OF JUSTICE AND SOLIDARITY. DO
YOU WE ENTRUST ALL THOSE WHOSE
LIVE IN FEAR FOR THEIR LIVES.
MAY THEY NOT YIELD TO DISCOURAGE
MEN AND DESPAIR BUT BECOME
HERALDS NEW HOPE TO ONE ANOTHER
IN THE SIXTH THROUGH ORDINARILY
CHALLENGING TIMES. INSPIRE ALL
OF US TO ONE OF HEART AND MIND
THE WALLS OF HOSTILITY AND
DIVISION CAN BE ELIMINATED.
MAYBE MORE GENEROUSLY FOR THE
COMMON GOOD. RESPECTING THE
DIGNITY AND FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS
OF EVERY PERSON MAYOR VOICE
RESOUND IN OUR HEARTS IF YOU
CALL ON US TO FOLLOW THE PATH.
OF RECONCILIATION AND PEACE WE
ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN. ALEX
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. THE WHOLE. THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND GUESTS A COUPLE
OF QUICK ANNOUNCEMENTS WE ARE
JOINED THIS MORNING BY VERY
SPECIAL GUESTS UP IN THE GALLERY
. FORMER REPUBLICAN LEADER
SENATOR BOB HUFF. WE ALSO HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY
IS A VERY SPECIAL DAY FOR ONE OF
OUR MEMBERS HAPPY BIRTHDAY
SENATOR EDMUND. MEMBERS WE DO
HAVE SOME BUSINESS TO CONDUCT
TODAY MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEEMED RED AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE
TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WE HAVE. ONE MOTION-
ITEM SEVENTEEN- PURSUANT TO
SENATE BILL. SIX USE ME IN
PERSON TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINETEEN SEE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B.
THREE FIFTY ONE. WE'RE GONNA
RECOGNIZE MEMBERS FOR MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
SENATOR BACKER. I UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE A MOTION TODAY. THAT THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RETURN SP
FIVE A FORD ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER
ACTION WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
MOTION IS ADOPTED BY THE-
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE ARE ANY
OTHER MOTIONS OR RESOLUTIONS ARE
NOTICES. FROM MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR SEEING NONE WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE WE HAVE ONE ITEM
UNDER UNFINISHED BUSINESS ITEM
FIVE. MR BRADFORD'S INNER
BRADFORD ON SCR SIXTY TWO. IN
REFERENCE I THANK YU MR
PRESIDENT I'M SORRY MR AFTER LET
ME LET THE SECRETARY READ I
APOLOGIZE SECRETARY. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY TWO
BY SENATOR BRADFORD RELATIVE TO
REFERENCE DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT SCR SIXTY TWO IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE- THIS RESOLUTION
WAS AMENDED AND- ASSEMBLY- DO A
DRAFTING ERROR AND I RESPECT
THAT STRUGGLE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR- BRADFORD MEMBERS
THIS ITEM IS BACKPACKING
CURRENTS FROM THE ASSEMBLY. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA FIVE
ATKINS I EIGHT FIVE BECKER I FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD HI BYRON I.
PROTESTING. DALLY FIVE DOT HI
TORONTO HI A GUNMAN FIVE GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROW. I PURCHASE
FOR FIVE WEST SO I HER TADO.
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S FIVE MIN FIVE NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH.
PAM HI FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT
FIVE REVERE HI SKINNER I STERN I
AM BERG FIVE WHITE HOUSE SPEAKER
I WINNER I WILL. I. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. IF YOU ARE
HAVING ON CALL MR PRESIDENT
WE'LL CALL HER TADO. A TROUBLED
MOVE THE CALL ON THIS ITEM
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
SENATE THIRD READING FILE WE
HAVE TWO ITEMS ON THE THIRD
READING ITEMS ELEVEN AND TWELVE
WE WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM ELEVEN
CENTER LEMOND S. R. NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR LAMONT RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL CAREGIVERS DAY CENTER
LEVEL. THANK YOU PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES S. R. SIXTY EIGHT
RECOGNIZES FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH
AT THE NATIONAL CAREGIVERS DAY
PROFESSIONAL CAREGIVERS AND
FAMILY CAREGIVERS ARE LIFELINES
TO MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO
NEED ASSISTANCE WITH MEDICAL
PERSONAL AND END OF LIFE CARE.
CARE GIVERS HAVE BEEN PROCLAIMED
THE ULTIMATE FORM OF LOVE AND
RESPECT AND AS A STATE AND
COUNTRY WE SHOULD SUPPORT AND
DEMONSTRATE OUR GRATITUDE FOR
CARE GIVERS AND THEIR ROLE IN
THE FILLING INTO. AN
INDIVIDUAL'S DESIRE TO REMAIN AT
HOME. THE HOME CARE INDUSTRY IS
AMONG THE FASTEST GROWING HEALTH
CARE INDUSTRY IN OUR STATE THEY
HAVE STEPPED UP DURING THE
CHALLENGES OF COPING NINETEEN
NOT ONLY CARING FOR THEIR
CLIENTS BUT ALSO RISKING THEIR
OWN PERSONAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
WHILE DOING SO. THEREFORE IT IS
MY HONOR TO RECOGNIZE FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS
NATIONAL CAREGIVERS DAY TO
RECOGNIZE CAREGIVERS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND THE UNITED STATES
WHO'S COMPASSIONATE CARE ENABLES
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO ARE
AGING OR WHO HAVE A DISABILITY
TO REMAIN AS INDEPENDENT AS
POSSIBLE IN THEIR OWN HOMES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU CEREMONY. MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON SR
SIXTY EIGHT ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE SECRETARY
I'M SORRY SENATOR NEWMAN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION- I'D
LIKE TO COMMEND THE WONDERFUL
MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK AND CARE
GIVING FOR DONNELLY S. YEAH YOU
BUT ASK ME UT W. THE WORK THAT
THEY DO IS IMPORTANT- AND IT
DESERVES EVERY BIT OF OUR
RESPECT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS. BASED I
BACKER HI FORGES I BRADFORD I
HAVE A I PROTESTING. DALLY I DON
I ZERO BY ADMIN FIVE GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH. I HEARD
SPURRED BY WESTERN. HI HER TADO
JONES I CAN WATER I LAYERED I
LABOUR I LIVE ALONE HI WIRE.
FIVE MELINDA'S I MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. PAM I
FORTINO I BROUGHT HI RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN I AM BERG HI FI
CASKEY I WINNER I WILL. I REMOVE
THE CALL ON THIS ITEM LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN WE'RE MOVING TO FIND
TWELVE. WHICH IS OUR FINAL ITEM
OF THE DAY EXCEPT FOR SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS AFTER THAT. AND-
SOME GERMAN IN MEMORIES. SO
EVERYBODY CAN- PREPARE TO TAKE
THEIR SEATS FOR THE GERMAN
MEMORIES AFTER THIS ITEM THAT
WOULD BE GREAT ITEM TWELVE IS
THAT C. R. NUMBER SEVENTY TWO
SENATOR PORN TINO. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR FORTINO RELATIVE TO PTA
DAY SENATOR PORN TO KNOW YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT IN COLLEGE TODAY I
PROUDLY RISE TO HONOR. AND TO
PRESENT S. C. R. SEVENTY TWO
WHICH RECOGNIZES THE NATIONAL
PARENT TEACHER ASSOCIATION ON A
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY. THE PTA CONNECTS
FAMILIES SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES
AND HAS BECOME AN INTEGRAL PART
OF THE FOUNDATION OF A GOOD
PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATION SYSTEM
IN OUR STATE AND ACROSS THE
NATION. IT HAS IT IS A TRUSTED
MESSENGER TO MILLIONS OF PARENTS
FAMILIES EDUCATORS AND ALLIED
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
THE PTA HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
ESTABLISHING PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TO IMPROVE TRIALS LIVES
INCLUDING SCHOOL NUTRITION
PROGRAMS CHILD LABOR LAWS PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICES THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM THE CREATION OF
KINDERGARTEN THE ADVANCEMENT OF
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT THE GROWTH OF
ARTS IN EDUCATION. AND LATER
SCHOOL START TIMES I'VE ALSO
PARTNERED WITH MY LOCAL PTA ON
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID CLASSES
WERE WE'VE HAD HUNDREDS OF
PARENTS COME IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE PTA. TO HELP US GET THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC AND OTHER MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THAT AFFECT OUR
STUDENTS THE FOUNDERS OF THE PTA
PHOEBE ASK PERSON HURST AND
ALICE MCLELLAN BIRNEY AND THE
FOUNDER OF THE NATIONAL CONGRESS
OF COLORED PARENTS AND TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. SELENA SLOAN BUTLER
WERE WOMEN OF IMAGINATION AND
COURAGE WHO UNDERSTOOD THE POWER
OF INDIVIDUAL ACTION. THEY WORK
BEYOND THE ACCEPTED BARRIERS OF
THEIR DAY AND TOOK ACTION THAT
LITERALLY CHANGED THE WORLD AND
CERTAINLY THE FUTURE OF MILLIONS
OF STUDENTS TODAY THE PTA HAS A
LOCAL PARENT TEACHER
ASSOCIATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND ITS MEMBERS REPRESENT
THE ETHNIC DIVERSITY OF THE
NATION AND COME FROM THE RANKS
OF ALL FAMILIES WHO TOGETHER
CONTINUE TO SERVE AS THE
CONSCIENCE OF THE COUNTRY FOR
OUR CHILDREN AND YOUTH. THE
FIRST DISTRICT PTA LOCATED IN
THE TWENTY FIFTH STATE SENATE
DISTRICT WHICH I'M PROUD TO
REPRESENT WAS THE FIRST PARENT
TEACHER ASSOCIATION DISTRICT
ESTABLISHED IN THE CAL IN
CALIFORNIA. IN NINETEEN WELL.
FIRST DISTRICT PROVIDES SUPPORT
LEADERSHIP AND COMMUNICATION
SERVICES TO OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY. SCHOOL PTA ASSOCIATIONS
AND TWENTY ONE LOCAL COUNCILS
WHICH COLLECTIVELY REPRESENT
OVER EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
PARENTS TEACHERS STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND SERVES
CHILDREN FROM BURBANK. TO POMONA
SO I PROUDLY JOIN AS A PROUD PTA
MEMBER AS THE SPOUSE OF A PTA
MEMBER AND AS A PARENT OF TWO
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS. TO ASK
YOU TO PROUDLY SUPPORT S. C. R.
SEVENTY TWO AND ASKS THE STATE
TO COMMEMORATE FOREVER FEBRUARY
SEVENTEENTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO AS P. T. A DAY IN HONOR OF
THEIR HUNDRED TWENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR FORTINO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
RUBIO YOUR RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. T.
R. SEVENTY TWO AND JOIN MY GOOD
FRIEND SENATOR FROM LOCKING OUT
ON AND RECOGNIZING THIS AMAZING
GROUP OF PARENTS AND INDIVIDUALS
TO CELEBRATE THE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
NATIONAL PARENT TEACHER.
ASSOCIATION AND A CLOSE FEBRUARY
SEVENTEENTH AS PTA DAY I THINK
WE ALL KNOW US PARENTS AS PTA
MEMBERS MYSELF AS AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TEACHER BUT THE REAL
POWER IN A SCHOOL COMMUNITY IS
IN THE HANDS OF THE WONDERFUL
PARENTS THAT HELP US EACH AND
EERY DAY. FROM ORGANIZING
EVENTS TO FUNDRAISING TO HELP US
PAY FOR FIELD TRIPS TO COMING
INTO CLASSROOMS AND HELP HELP US
MANAGE SOME OF THE CELEBRATIONS
I JUST WANT TO HONOR ALL THOSE
PARENTS THAT STEPPED IN AND I
HAVE TO ALSO RECOGNIZE THOSE
THAT DON'T MAKE IT INTO THE
SCHOOL. BUT ALSO SEND RESOURCES
COOKIES FOOD WHATEVER WE ASK
THAT THEY ARE THERE TO DELIVER
CELL SO I CAN NOT ONLY THOSE
THAT ARE PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN
OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITY BUT THEY'LL
SET UP LIFT US AND HELP US WITH
ALL OUR EFFORTS SO AGAIN I
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
GREAT SENATOR BLOCKING OUT OF
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. FOR
PARTICIPATING HIMSELF AS A PTA
MEMBER AND- HIS WIFE FOR ALSO
JOINING THE PTA SO WITH THAT.
COLLEAGUES I ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON SCR SEVENTY TWO ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS
. EIGHT I BACKER. HI FORGES FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE.
DALLY I DON I TORONTO HI ADNAN I
GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATE I GROW.
FIVE HEARD SPURRED BY WESTERN. I
HER TADO. JONES I CAN WATER I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON HI
WIRE I MELINDA'S HI MAN I.
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A TROUBLE HI
PAM HI FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT
HI RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG I WOULD HAVE SEEN I WINNER
. I WELL I. PLEASE CALL THE
UPSET MEMBERS ATKINS. CORTEZ
THREE FURTADO. I IS THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS IS ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MEMBERS WE ARE GONNA
MOVE BACK ON THE TWO ITEMS ARE
ON CALL AND LIFT THE CALL LET'S
LEAVE THE CALL ADAM FIVE FIRSTS
MADAM SECRETARY. CORTELLI HER
TADO BUT YOU ARE BOTH I. WITH
EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO MAJOR
PASSES WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM ELEVEN. M. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ATTENDEES CORTEZ
THREE. HER TADO OCHO A BOAT I.
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS IS ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE TO
COMMIT THAT CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS OF THE DAY WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS AND SOME
ADJOURNMENT MEMORIES- IF WE CAN
ALL TAKE OUR SEATS AND BE
PREPARED FOR THAT- COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENT CENTER BY CAL SKI
YOU HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT THIS
MORNING. I SENT MY CAST YOU ONE
MORE TIME. THE BUDGET OFFICE
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE TO
WILL MEET FIFTEEN MINUTES UPON
THE GERMAN IN THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. THANK YOU SIR BYE CASKEY
SUB TWO AND THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE FIFTEEN MINUTES UPON A
GERMAN CENTRE AGNES I HAVE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THIS MORNING. SUB
THREE WILL BEGIN AT IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE FIFTEEN MINUTES
AFTER THE CONCLUSION OF SESSION
THANK YOU SENATOR EDMUND SUB
THREE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
FIFTEEN MINUTES UPON GERMAN OF
THE SESSION. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO THE MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS WERE GONNA
RIP RECOGNIZE. A FEW SENATORS
FOR GERMANS IN MEMORY WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN THIS MORNING WITH
CENTRE ALAN. FOR BETTY WHITE
CENTER ALLEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE FLOOR. MEMBERS IT'S WITH
THAT DEEP SADNESS THAT I RISE TO
REQUEST THAT WE TURN THE MEMORY
OF THE REVERED BETTY WHITE. WHO
SADLY PASSED AWAY AT HER
BRENTWOOD HOME ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST JUST BEFORE HER ONE
HUNDREDTH BIRTHDAY. BETTY WAS
BORN ON JANUARY SEVENTEENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWO IN
OAK PARK ILLINOIS SHE MOVED TO
LA. AT A YOUNG AGE OR THEIR
PARENTS AMID THE- IN THE MIDST
OF THE GREAT DEPRESSION. SHE'S
BEEN THERE FOR TEN YEARS IN MY
DISTRICT HE WENT TO BEVERLY
HILLS HIGH SCHOOL WHERE SHE
APPEARED. IN SEVERAL STUDENT
PRODUCTIONS YOU GRADUATE
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE EVENTUALLY
LANDED HER FIRST PROFESSIONAL
PERFORMANCE GIG. AT A LOCAL
THEATER. AND SHE TRANSITIONED
EASILY TO THE NEW MEDIUM I'M
URGING MEDIUM OF TELEVISION- AS
THE FIRST LADY OF TELEVISION SHE
WAS. ONE OF THE FIRST WOMEN TO
WORK BOTH IN FRONT OF AND BEHIND
THE CAMERA. AS WELL AS THE FIRST
WOMAN TO CO PRODUCE AND OWN A
SIT COM THE HIT SHOW LIFE WITH
ELIZABETH. IN THE EARLY FIFTIES
SHE HOSTED AND PRODUCED THE
DAILY TALK AND VARIETY SHOW
CALLED THE BETTY WHITE SHOW.
EXERCISING CREATIVE CONTROL OVER
THE SERIES SHE HIRED A FEMALE
DIRECTORS YOU FEATURED. AFTER
MAKING THIRTEEN ARTHUR DUNCAN IN
THE FACE OF BOYCOTTS FROM
STATIONS DURING- THE JIM CROW
ERA SOUTH SHE ACTUALLY DOUBLE
DOWN AND GAVE DUNCAN MORE AIR
TIME. AS SHE HAD A CAREER
SPANNING EIGHT MEMORABLE DECADES
HER TELEVISION AND FILM RESUMES
EXTENSIVE INCLUDES ICONIC ROLES
IS. THROUGH AN EVENING- SEA AND
ISLANDS IN THE MARY TYLER MOORE
SHOW. A ROSE NYLUND A COURSE IN
IN GOLDEN GIRLS. WHEN MY
GRANDMA'S FAVORITE SHOWS AND- A
COUPLE MY STAFF TO ACTUALLY. AND
SHE RECEIVED NUMEROUS AWARDS
OVER HER LIFETIME CAREER IN
ENTERTAINMENT INCLUDING FIVE
PRIMETIME EMMYS AND TWO SCREEN
ACTORS GUILD AWARDS. OUTSIDE OF
ENTERTAINMENT ANIMALS WERE HER
PASSION. HE WAS A DEDICATED
PHILANTHROPIST FOUNDER OF
NUMEROUS ANIMAL WELFARE AND
RESCUE CHARITIES- HER LOVE
ANIMALS BEGAN EARLY AS OUR
FAMILY WAS KNOWN TO HAVE
COUNTLESS NUMBERS OF PETS AND IT
WAS DURING FAMILY CAMPING TRIPS
IN THE SIERRA NEVADA THEIR LOVE
OF NATURE AND ANIMALS DEEP INTO
THE POINTS YOU CONSIDERED
ACTUALLY BECOMING A FOREST
RANGER. AND HOW AFTER HER
PASSING FANS WERE INSPIRED TO
CONTRIBUTE TO ANIMAL SHELTERS
AND RESCUES NONPROFITS ALL OVER
THE WORLD. SHE WAS PRECEDED IN
DEATH BY HER HUSBAND ALLEN
LUDDEN- SURVIVED BY. THREE STEP
CHILDREN DAVID MARTIN SERRA AND
I UST WANNA. ASK THAT WE
CONTINUE TO CHERISH HER MEMORY
INSPIRED BY HER EVERLASTING
LEGACY. SHE WAS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PIONEER FOR WOMEN. IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IN A
BELOVED FIGURE WHO MADE US ALL
LAUGH. VERY WELL ANYWAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALAN PLEASE BRING
HIS WIFE'S NAME FORWARD TO THE
DESK SO THAT SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. THERE IS A GENERAL
MOVING ON TO CENTER GROVE WHO
WILL BE. JOINING IN MEMORY FOR
RICHARD PAUL SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION
TO THE PORTRAIT AT THE FRONT OF
THE CHAMBER. TWO MONTHS AGO THE
SENATE HONORED THE CAREER AND
RETIREMENT OF RICHARD PAUL. WHO
HAD WORKED FOR THE SENATE FOR
MORE THAN THREE DECADES. SEVERAL
SENATORS RAISE THEIR MICROPHONE
TO PAY TRIBUTE TO RICHARD AS
BOTH AN AMAZING EMPLOYEE BUT
ALSO A WONDERFUL MAN WITH A
GENEROUS HEART. AND A KIND
LOVING SOUL. UNFORTUNATELY
RICHARD WAS NOT ABLE TO ATTEND
THE CEREMONY IN PERSON AS HE WAS
AT HOME IN THE FINAL STAGES OF
BATTLING THE CANCER THAT HAD
PLAGUED HIM SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN. I KNOW RICHARD
WHAT'S THE CEREMONY ON HIS
COMPUTER AND HE WAS EXTREMELY
MOVED- BECAUSE OF WHAT WAS SAID
ABOUT HIM BY ALL OF YOU. THAT
VERY DAY THAT WE WERE HONORING
HIM ON THE FLOOR THE DOCTORS
CAME IN AND TOLD HIM THAT HE
ONLY HAD TWO DAYS TO LIVE.
DESPITE THAT PREDICTION HE
CONTINUED TO FIGHT ANOTHER TWO
MONTHS CONTINUING TO MAZE ALL OF
THOSE AROUND HIM WITH HIS
MODESTY. AND GOOD CHEER. I'M
DEEPLY SADDENED TO TELL YOU THAT
THIS INCREDIBLE MAN THIS BROTHER
THIS FRIEND. THIS HUMOROUS
INDIVIDUAL THEY GAVE THREE
DECADES TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PASSED AWAY THIS THIS
MONDAY. MORNING AT HIS HOME. I
HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT AS AN
EMPLOYER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I DEEPLY CARE ABOUT
MY EMPLOYEES ESPECIALLY THOSE
THAT HAVE WORKED FOR ME FOR A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME. I SHARE
THIS WITH YOU TO TELL YOU THAT I
BELIEVE THAT- INTERESTS THE
SECRETARY OF ARSENIC CARES
DEEPLY ABOUT ALL OF THE
EMPLOYEES. THAT ARE UNDER HER.
AND SHE DID SOME EXTRAORDINARY
THINGS TO MAKE SURE THAT RICHARD
AND HIS FAMILY WERE TAKEN CARE
OF AND I THINK THAT SPEAKS
VOLUMES OF OUR SECRETARY. AND I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
WAS MENTIONED. DESPITE ALL OF
RICHARD'S CHALLENGES AND
EVERYTHING THAT HE FACED. HE
NEVER LET THE DISEASE DEFINE HIM
OR HIS SPIRIT. RICHARD FOR ALL
O THE STEPS SUFFERING THAT HE'D
GONE THROUGH WITH EXTRAORDINARY
COURAGE UNPARALLELED THREE
REMARKABLE RESILIENCY AN
ABSOLUTE GRACE AND EVEN HUMOR.
HE WAS BEING RELEASED TO GO BACK
HOME WHEN HE WAS IN A
REHABILITATION CENTER AND I
OFTEN CALLED TO CHECK ON HIM AND
PRAYED WITH HIM. AND I SAID HEY
HOW'S IT GOING WHEN I CALLED HIM
AND HE GOES IT'S GOING OKAY I
SAID WHAT DOES THAT MEAN AND HE
GOES WELL MISS GROUP HAVE YOU
EVER TRIED TO GET DRESSED
WITHOUT LEGS. I SAID NO I
HAVEN'T HE GOES WELL TODAY WAS
MY FIRST TIME AND I DID IT IN A
RECORD FORTY SEVEN MINUTES. AND
EVEN AT THAT MOMENT HE CHUCKLED
I'M CRYING ON THE OTHER END OF
THE PHONE. AND HE'S HE'S LIKE I
DID IT AND HE'S GOT A CHUCKLE IN
HIS VOICE. I KNOW THAT RICHARD
FACE THIS CHALLENGE IN HIS LIFE
. WITH GREAT FAITH. AND I KNOW
THAT HE HAD A SOUL FULL OF HOPE
THEY CARRIED HIM THROUGH ALL
THESE DIFFICULT YEARS AND HIS
STRENGTH INSPIRED MANY INCLUDING
MYSELF. I KNOW THAT RICHARD IS
IN HEAVEN WITH HIS LORD AND
SAVIOR JESUS CHRIST. AND I KNOW
THAT THE SCRIPTURE SAYS THAT
JESUS WILL WIPE AWAY EVERY TEAR.
FROM YOUR EYES THERE WILL BE NO
MORE DEATH OR SORROW. OR CRYING
OR PAIN. AND THAT THESE THINGS
WILL BE FOR EVER GONE. SO TO
RICHARD PAUL WHO WALKS THE
STREETS OF HEAVEN RIGHT NOW WITH
JESUS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEDICATED SERVICE OF THIRTY
YEARS TO THE CITIZENS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. COLLEAGUES
PLEASE ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF
RICHARD PAUL. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOT ON THIS ITEM CENTER DOT. AS
CHAIR OF G. I'D LIKE TO ADD MY
CENTER DOT STAND BY FOR JUST A
SECOND PLEASE DON'T GET YOUR
MICROPHONE GOING. RIGHT MR
PRESIDENT. YEAH MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- PHIL- DO YOU EVER GO.
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
APPRECIATED THE CENTER DIED YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE SITE AND
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
AS CHAIR OF THE GEO COMMITTEE I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD MY VOICE TO
THE CHURN IN MEMORY OF RICHARD
PAUL WHO SERVED AS REPUBLICAN
GEO CONSULTANT FOR TWENTY SIX
YEARS. THERE'S NOT MUCH MORE I
CAN SAY THAT HASN'T ALREADY BEEN
SAID HOWEVER I DO FEEL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
RICHARD WAS NOT JUST A FRIEND
AND A MENTOR TO REPUBLICAN MET
MEMBERS AND STAFF BUT TO ANYBODY
WHO HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE OF
WORKING WITH HIM. I KNOW MY
SENATE GEO STAFF BOTH PAST AND
PRESENT I THOUGHT THE WORLD OF
HIM AS I DID. AND WE'LL MISS HIM
DEARLY. WE SPEAK A LOT IN THIS
BUILDING OF THE SENATE FAMILY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT FAMILY
HAS LOST ONE OF ITS OLDEST AND
MOST CHERISHED NUMBERS. THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF RICHARD
PAUL THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU
pSENATOR DODD BOTH- ADJOURNMENT
REQUESTS ARE VERY APTLY PLACED
ON THE FLOOR. IF THE MEMBERS OF
PLEASE BRING MISTER RICHARD
PAUL'S NAME TO THE DESK SO THAT
HE CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE THE
CENTER PANEL. FOR WAYNE CYBER.
CENTER PENN. THANK YOU. MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS I RISE TO
TURN A MEMORY OF WAYNE TIVO AND
INTERNATIONALLY RENOWNED ARTISTS
WHO PASSED AWAY IN DECEMBER
TWENTY FIFTH- LAST YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT THE AGE OF A
HUNDRED ONE. MR TIVO ENTERED HIS
UNDERGRADUATE GRADUATE DEGREES
IN FINE ARTS AT SACRAMENTO STATE
COLLEGE NOW. CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SACRAMENTO SAC STATE. AND
SHORTLY AFTER COLLEGE HE BEGAN A
LONG AND INCREDIBLY INFLUENTIAL
CAREERS A PIONEER IN POP ART.
DURING HIS TIME AS A GRADUATE
STUDENT BEGAN TEACHING IN WHAT'S
NOW SEGMENT CITY COLLEGE AND
LATER ON HIS LIFE HE CONTINUES
CAREER AS AN EDUCATOR. BECOMING
A PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DAVIS. AS ONE OF THE
ONLY NORTHERN CALIFORNIA'S BUT
THE NATION'S MOST CELEBRATED
ARTISTS HE WAS BEST KNOWN FOR
HIS ASSOCIATION WITH POP ART.
AND HIS STILL LIFE DEPICTIONS OF
DESSERTS AND DINER FOODS. OVER
THE SPN OF HIS CAREER THE
CROCKER ART MUSEUM HERE HAS.
HELD A TIVO EXHIBITION
EXHIBITION EACH DECADE HOSTING
HIS FIRST SOLO SHOW BACK IN
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE. AND LAST
YEAR THEY DID CELEBRATE HIS
HUNDRED BIRTHDAY BY FEATURING
HIS HUNDRED CAREER SPANNING
WORKS. TODAY REMEMBER WHEN TIVO
AND INFLUENTIAL TECHNO ART
TEACHER AND INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED ARTIST. WILL BE
MISSED BY HIS FAMILY FRIENDS IN
THE ART WORLD I ASK THAT WE
TURNED IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR PAN IF YOU COULD
PLEASE BRING MR T. WAS NAMED TO
THE DESK SO THAT HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. NEXT
WE'RE GONNA RECOGNIZE SENATOR
WIENER. SENATOR YOU HAVE THE
FOUR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH- PROFOUND
SADNESS THAT I. RISE TODAY TO
HOUSE OF THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF A FORMER. STAFFER OF
THE SENATOR FROM THE DISTRICT
STAFFER ON A DUMMY ON A- GREAT
LEADER IN SAN FRANCISCO'S LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. AND SOMEONE WHO WORKS
. IN THE DISTRICT OFFICE FOUR
SENATOR MARK LENO- FOR ACTUALLY
FOR HIS ENTIRE FOURTEEN YEARS IN
THE LEGISLATURE FIRST IN HIS
FAMILY AND THEN IN THE SENATE
AND BEFORE THAT FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. KEVIN SHELLY- ON A
ACCORD SAMUS IS GOING HOME FOR
ABOUT FORTY YEARS HE WAS. A KEY
PART OF OUR COMMUNITY FOR. SO
VERY VERY DIFFICULT AND
TURBULENT TIMES IN SAN FRANCISCO
THROUGHOUT THE WORST EVER HIV
AIDS CRISIS. AFTER ALL OF THE
FIGHTS AROUND LGBTQ CIVIL RIGHTS
. OUR THE QUALITY- AND SO ME
UPLIFTING MOMENTS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND ON IT WAS ALWAYS
THERE- SHE WORKED FOR MANY
YEARS- PACIFIC BELL AS A
TECHNICIAN AND OPERATOR AND AS A
SHOP STEWARD- FOR THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS. OF
AMERICA. ON WAS ONE OF MY MOTHER
WOULD CALL A JOINER- SHE- COULD
NOT PASS UP OPPORTUNITY- TO
SERVICE ONE SERVICE WAS- WAS WAS
NECESSARY. SHE SPENT MANY MANY
YEARS ON THE BOARD OF THE ALICE
B. TOKLAS LGBTQ DEMOCRATIC CLUB
WHICH IS HOW I GOT TO KNOW ON A-
MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS AGO SHE
WAS A CORE MEMBER OF THE CLUB-
AND SUGGESTED AMAZING AMAZING
WORK- IN OUR COMMUNITY IN TERMS
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY. AND
GRASSROOTS ALSO PARTICULAR
POLITICAL ACTIVISM- SHE ALSO
SERVED AS BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE
GOLDEN GATE BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS OUR BUSINESS
OWNS A SMALL
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS IN THE AREA
FOR WOMEN- THE UCSF WOMEN'S
HEALTH PATIENT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE- SERVICES FOR PRIDE.
AND THE GOLDEN GATE- FLYERS ON-
WAS- I'LL BE HONEST A PERSONAL
FRIEND OF MINE- I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT- SHOES CREDIBLY CLOSE CLOSE
WITH SENATOR MCCONNELL AND- THIS
IS A HUE LOSS. FOR MY FOR MY
PREDECESSOR. TIME SHE WAS
SOMEONE WHO'S VERY WELL KNOWN IN
THE- US. ALWAYS IN PURPLE THAT
WAS HER TRADEMARK- AND SO SHE
WAS THE PURPLE LADY WALKING DOWN
THE STREET ARE GOING ON THE
STREET IN A WHEELCHAIR- AND SHE
ALSO. ALWAYS HAD IN HER POCKET-
TREATS FOR DOGS- AND SO THE DOGS
AREN'T NEW THE ISSUE IS THE TREE
LIGHTING- AND THEY'LL BE VERY
HAPPY WHEN THEY WOULD SEE HER-
AND THESE SORT OF. LITTLE THINGS
THESE TOUCHES ON ARE WHAT MAKE
PEOPLE SO SPECIAL IN SO MANY
WAYS IN OUR COMMUNITY ON A WAS-
IN ADDITION TO HER GREAT
LEADERSHIP. HAS ONE OF THESE
WONDERFUL PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT PEOPLE LOOK
FORWARD. TO SEEING SHOULD
INCREDIBLE ENERGY ON ANA
STRUGGLED. WITH HEALTH ISSUES
FOR MANY MANY MANY YEARS- BUT
DESPITE ALL OF THOSE HEALTH
ISSUES. SHE WAS ALWAYS STILL
INVOLVED. SHE WAS ALWAYS STILL
WORKING AFTER CENTER LINE- LEFT
HIS BODY SHE- ULTIMATELY WENT TO
WORK FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT SHE WORKED
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC- I WOULD
SEE HER IN THE CASTRO TO THE
NORTH VALLEY- AND SHE'S VERY HAD
SIGNIFICANT MOBILITY PROBLEMS.
MR ALWAYS GET FROM THE NOISE NO
VALUE TO CASTRO AND IF YOU KNOW
THAT THERE IS A HUGE HILL IN
BETWEEN. I NEVER QUITE
UNDERSTOOD HOW SHE GOT AROUND
BUT SHE DID SHE WAS JUST A
DETERMINES. POSITIVE ENERGY KIND
OF PERSON WHO WAS NEVER GOING TO
GO ABOUT LIFE THAT HER DOWN AS
SHE PASSED ON FRIDAY EVENING-
MAJOR SURPRISE AND- SAYS TRAGEDY
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE. IN OUR
COMMUNITY- AND ON- WE LOVE YOU
WE MISS. YOU REST IN PEACE.
SEVERAL ON THE SIDE OF. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT AND I
THINK IT'S A HIGH RISE ALSO TO
ADJOURN AN HONEST MEMORY AND IT
IS HARD TO. TO ADD TO WHAT THE
SENATOR JUST SAID BECAUSE I
SERVED IN THE SAME CLASS WITH
WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER LENO DID A
LOT OF THINGS IN SAN FRANCISCO
WAS VERY CLOSE TO ANA BUT AS WAS
JUST SAID SHE WAS A RESIDENT OF
THE NORTH VALLEY. AS WAS MY
CRAZY BROTHER WHO WAS A NEIGHBOR
AND HE WAS NURSING A POWER BACK
TO HEALTH FROM HIS RANCH AND
SHUTTLING BACK AND FORTH. FROM
THE CAPE PAY VALLEY TO THE NORTH
VALLEY AND I GET A TEXT FROM ON
A- THAT PLACE ON WHAT WAS JUST
SAID BECAUSE MY BROTHER WAS
WALKING A COW. AND RAN INTO ON A
AND SHE SAID I'VE TREATS FOR
DOGS BUT I CAN'T DEAL WITH THIS
. AND SHE WAS STANDING NEXT TO
HIM WHEN I'M SURE SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT REPRESENT
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS SHE WAS
STANDING NEXT TO ONE SOMEBODY
WALKED UP TO HIM AND SAID WHAT
KIND OF DOG IS THAT AND SO SHE
HAD THE SENSE OF HUMOR THAT WENT
COMPLETELY WITH EVERYTHING ELSE
AND I WILL REALLY MISS HER
APPRECIATE THE TRIBUTE. TO HER
AND RISE TO ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY AS WELL. THANK YOU
SENATORS IF YOU CAN BRING HIS
DUMMY ANI'S NAME FORWARD TO THE
DESTINATION BE PROBABLY MEMORIZE
MOM MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. THEIR
WINNER YOU'RE RECOGNIZED I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IT'S
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE
TO ASK THAT THE SENATOR IN
MEMORY. OF CHARLOTTE SHULTZ-
PHILANTHROPIST- AND SAN
FRANCISCO'S BY FAR AND AWAY
LONGER SERVICE LONG SERVING
CHIEF OF PROTOCOL. CHARLOTTE
SHULTZ- AS YOU MAY KNOW- WAS
MARRIED TO FORMER SECRETARY OF
STATE GEORGE SHULTZ. WHO
TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY LAST YEAR
IN FEBRUARY- CHARLOTTE WAS FROM
A SMALL TOWN IN THE TEXAS.
PANHANDLE IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS ASEAN ARE. FORMER
SPEAKER AND MAYOR WILLIE BROWN-
BONDED SO MUCH THAT YOU COULD
NOT HAVE BEEN MORE DIFFERENT-
BUT THEY WERE BOTH TEXANS APART-
BUT SHE EMBRACED SAN FRANCISCO
AS OUR HOME TOWN IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES. AS SAN FRANCISCO'S
CHIEF OF PROTOCOL SHE WAS NO
DOUBT THE LONGEST SERVING AN
ELECTED PUBLIC OFFICIAL IN SAN
FRANCISCO- WORKING AS UNDER TEN
DIFFERENT MAYORS. FOR FIFTY ONE
YEARS. THE ENTIRE TIME UNPAID TO
DOING THE WORK- TO REALLY FOSTER
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE REST OF THE
WORLD- SHE WORKED WITH OVER
EIGHTY CONSULS GENERAL-
CEMENTING BONDS WITH EIGHTEEN.
OUR SISTER CITIES HE PROMOTED
BUSINESS EDUCATION AND CULTURAL
INITIATIVES WITH VISITING
DIGNITARIES- SHE ARRANGED FOR
DECADES MY ORAL TRAVELS AROUND
THE WORLD. SHE PROMOTED
EDUCATION AND BUSINESS AND TOOK
ON SO MANY CULTURAL INITIATIVES
WITH VISITING DIGNITARIES
INCLUDING QUEEN ELIZABETH THE
SECOND OF THE UNITED KINGDOM IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE AND POPE
JOHN PAUL THE SECOND IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. HER KINDNESS AND
COMMITMENT WERE APPRECIATED BY
SO MANY AND IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN SHE WAS NAMED HONORARY
COMMANDER OF THE ROYAL VICTORIAN
ORDER. BY QUEEN ELIZABETH. I'M
SURE THAT WAS A CIVIC LEADER WHO
IS DEEPLY COMMITTED. TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND FRANKLY TO THE
ENTIRE STATE- WITH THE SCHEDULE
THAT SO OFTEN HAD HER WORKING
FROM EARLY MORNING UNTIL LATE AT
NIGHT. REGARDLESS OF HER AGE SHE
HAD THIS INCREDIBLE ENERGY. SHE
ALSO MANAGED TO FIND TIME TO SIT
ON THE BOARDS OF DIRECTORS OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO MUSEUM OF
MODERN ART. SAN FRANCISCO OPERA
SAN FRANCISCO SYMPHONY SAN
FRANCISCO BALLET SAN FRANCISCO
WAR MEMORIAL AND PERFORMING ARTS
CENTER AND THE COMMONWEALTH CLUB
. SHE ALSO WAS A BOARD MEMBER OF
GRACE CATHEDRAL AS WELL AS THE
FINE ARTS MUSEUMS SAN FRANCISCO
AND MAKES ME. TIRED JUST TO
READ- NOT LESS BUT THAT WAS HER
ENERGY. SHE ALSO HAD AN AMAZING
SOMETIMES BITING BUT AN AMAZING.
SENSE OF HUMOR AND WISHED US
ALWAYS FUN. TO BE AROUND YOU
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING AROUND-
CHARLOTTE- SHE PASSED AWAY- IN
DECEMBER FROM COMPLICATIONS DUE
TO CANCER. THE MASSIVE MASSIVE
LOSS- TO CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN CHARLOTTE- WE MISS YOU REST
IN PEACE. SENATOR HERTZBERG ON
THE SIDE OF. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT WOULD JOIN. IN
ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY OF
CHARLOTTE SHOWS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO YOU
KNOW. WE ALL TALK ABOUT BEING
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY OR
FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY WHATEVER
WE ARE. AS WE DEAL GLOBALLY BUT
I THINK THE POINTS WERE MADE BY
HIM CENTER WINNER SOLE PORTANT
BECAUSE- THOSE THINGS DON'T
HAPPEN AUTOMATICALLY. IN TERMS
OF THOSE RELATIONSHIPS IT WASN'T
JUST- THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
SPEAKER BROWN BEAR BROWN HE WAS
HERE BUT WHEN SHE DID THE SAME
THING WHEN HE WAS HERE SPEAKER.
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER EVERY
GOVERNOR- SHE SHE WAS JUST
EXTRAORDINARY IN IN BUILDING
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND MAKING
SURE THAT. MATTERS OF CRITICAL
GLOBAL IMPORTANCE WERE TENDED TO
NEVER FORGET THREE DAYS BEFORE
NINE ONE ONE I WAS RACING TO.
SAN FRANCISCO FOR THE
CELEBRATION OF THE ARMISTICE
WITH ALL OF THE FORMER SECRETARY
OF STATE. FOREIGN MINISTERS
AMBASSADORS WHICH A PAN THE BIG
EVENTS THINGS THAT WERE
IMPORTANT THAT REMINDED US AND
KEPT US ON THE WORLD STAGE. AND
SO I ALWAYS LIKE TO SAY GOD IS
IN THE DETAILS AND IT IS THE
DETAILS IT IS NOT JUST OUR
ECONOMY BUT HIS CLOSE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS OF ALL THOSE
MINISTERS AND- DIGNITARIES AND
AMBASSADORS THAT SHE MADE SURE
THAT WE SAW AND TALKED WITH. AND
HELPED BUILD THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
CERTAINLY WITH RESPECT TO SAN
FRANCISCO. BUT SHE WAS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ROLE
THROUGH MANY ADMINISTRATIONS I
OBSERVED A MAN OR NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WHICH IS VERY MUCH
JUST WAIT. BUT BACK IN THOSE
DAYS DOING THE SAME THING
THERE'S CERTAIN PEOPLE THAT ARE
JUST STAND OUT AND MAKE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF CREDIT FOR. AND CHARLES
SCHULTZ IS ONE OF THOSE AND I
ASK THAT THIS IS THE BODY
TURNING HER MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR AS PER CENTERS IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE BRING
MICHELLE'S NAME FORWARD TO THE
DESK. SO THEY SHOULD BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THIS CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION
DURING THE GERMAN MEMORIES-
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS TODAY
SENATOR BATES THE DESK IS CLEAR. THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK HAS
CLEARED THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. AND WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM.
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS I
RETURN IT TO YOU MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
GERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE'LL RECONVENE MEMBERS ON
MONDAY AT TWO PM.